so we would actually I think we will be
probably a bit free before June uh with
everything extra that we have coming in
question
Why can't your family come visit you
guys in California
oh uh well my parents don't have a Visa
uh and unfortunately like I said you
know we're trying to break that cycle my
parents don't have a lot of money
they're like neither do you buy
yeah in my uh no no
you don't have a lot of money either
well that's true I want you to I want
you to sit with that for a minute
because it's very easy to look at
somebody else and go well I understand
why they can't spend the money but not
allow that same rhetoric to work for
yourself you don't have a lot of money
either you got forty four thousand
dollars in debt and good on you for
realizing okay we need to do something
to change that I'm just going to be
honest with you if it were me I would
wait I would wait until I can take this
trip and do this trip the way I want to
do this trip to where it's a blessing
it's not a burden it's not setting us
back you know I hear what you're saying
and the cause is Noble you you don't
want to repeat that cycle and making the
decision to take a trip that you can't
afford
is part of repeating that cycle you've
got to learn when it's okay to say no
when it's okay to say yes and how to
prioritize
um the habits that are going to help you
break that cycle
what do you got George well I'm
wondering by the time you take this trip
let's say you went in December January
how old will the baby be
uh baby would be a year and a half now
let's say you waited until you were
completely debt free and then saved up
and paid for this trip in cash how old
would the baby be by the time you went
on that trip
I would say around two or more so the
question is we're talking about the
baby's a year and a half versus two
years old but we're in a completely
different place financially yeah and so
I don't I don't see this as an emergency
of we have to go before the baby turns
18 months or else it's not it's gonna be
special not with cameras the way they
are maybe is not with cameras the way
they are and the internet's the way the
internet FaceTime once a week with the
baby and the grandparents until we do
this thing but I'm with Jade on making
this a blessing instead of a curse
because you said the reason you're doing
this is because you want to change your
family tree and break these generational
curses and part of that is sacrifice and
doing things that are weird things that
are uncomfortable things you're not
happy about right now but that will
cause you to have long-term success in
the future That's Where It's At hey we
appreciate that call Christina like
George and I said just this is part of
the sacrifice to win you feel it and
trust me uh Little Junior he's gonna
appreciate the sacrifices that his
parents made to win when he he's old
enough and able to talk and able to say
what he feels about it all right let's
take another call we got Sean from
Seattle Washington what's going on in
your world Sean
hey how are you guys doing we're doing
good how are you
doing all right I just had a general
like house question related to net worth
I know the Ramsey parameters about
15-year fixed on you know less than 25
of your take home but one thing that
I've never really heard of is how much
is too much when the house becomes like
a part of your net worth are there like
kind of safety nets around that or love
to get some clarity so you're feeling
like too too much of your net worth is
tied up in your personal residence
yeah
do you need to tap into this money soon
nope oh I mean when I look at okay so
Dave wrote a book baby steps
Millionaires and he talks about how
generally it breaks down to where a
third of your net worth is in your home
and two-thirds of it is in your
retirement accounts so that's kind of
what's normal
um
if you don't I'm how old are you
35.
what's your what's your concern here are
you concerned that over time you're not
going to be able to invest and kind of
balance that out
no I I just I'm trying to find a healthy
balance because the market I live in is
ridiculous yeah so if I'm moving to a
bigger home in the future I just want to
make sure that it fits within my numbers
and so I'm not trying to pull anything
out and I'm trying to get the baby step
seven at the end of the day but again
just the ratios I'm not too familiar so
I'll tell you Sean my situation because
I don't fall into the mold that we found
in baby steps millionaires I'm the
opposite we were super aggressive with
paying off our house because it creates
cash flow while we continue to live for
the next you know 20 30 years until we
retire and so over time you know my
two-thirds of my net worth is in my
house a third is in our retirement
accounts over time that's going to shift
I might have two three four million
dollars in retirement accounts by the
time we retire and my house is probably
not going to be worth four million
dollars at that point
and so it's not really about having an
equal ratio if you talk to a financial
planner they would probably say hey we
want it to have more equal footing
versus having way too much in-house and
you can't live on retirement so your
house isn't going to create an income
for you whereas your retirement account
will so the goal is really to say hey 20
30 years from now when I need to tap
into that retirement account is there
enough for me to where I don't have to
work anymore and I can choose to work
and so I would think of it more in terms
of your goals versus hitting a magical
parameter but it's a great question
interesting conversation yeah and you've
got time you've got plenty of time to be
investing 15 and for those of you who
are new to this conversation net worth
is what you own minus what you owe and
that's the only way to become a
millionaire is by calculating your net
worth it's not about how much income you
make right your income doesn't make you
a million you don't need to make a
million dollars you can make forty
thousand dollars and still become a
millionaire that's right this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw I am joined by my
good buddy George Campbell thank you for
saying that you know John always says
we're not friends even though we're
actually BFFs you know John doesn't have
any friends
shots fired John deloney if you're
listening I know you're feet away
listening well we we all actually like
each other Jade can we just put that out
there we have a great time we do and if
you want to be with us all in the same
room which is actually pretty rare you
need to join us for our smart conference
event next month it's an entire weekend
of good times and we're almost out of
tickets this thing is selling out wow
it's at our brand new Ramsay Event
Center just up the hill here from our
headquarters and in addition to giving
you life-changing practical and proven
wisdom to help you be successful in
every area of life we're going to
celebrate like crazy it's a good time
it's high energy live music April 14th
and 15th join myself Dave Ramsey Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis and Jade warshaw for an
amazing weekend we're going to talk
about how to crush dead find work that
you love improve your overall Wellness
build wealth all of it so we'd love to
meet you and hear your story and maybe
grab a photo sign a book or two and
don't forget because this is the first
event at the new Ramsey Event Center
every ticket includes a Special
Commemorative badge that's exciting I
hope I can get one
so general admission tickets are just
119 bucks each but they're almost gone
you don't want to miss this weekend
event go to ramseysolutions.com
events and grab yours today and Jay it's
going to be your first time speaking at
smart conference yes it is going to be
my first time I'm already preparing
George I hope so it's coming by ducks in
a row you better be preparing by now
this thing's coming up I know I'm
excited I can't wait to see you guys
there uh in the meantime let's go ahead
and take some calls George we got Eric's
in Phoenix Phoenix Arizona what's going
on out there Phoenix in Phoenix Eric
hey I'm a long time listener first time
caller been listening to Dave since the
early 2000s wow
quick question about my 401k and my Roth
401k contributions what's going on I am
dead for I am debt free except for my
house
and putting 15 away into retirement
accounts my question is
according to what I read my Ross 401K I
can put up a total contribution of 22
500 into my Roth right in my my company
will mask me a certain percentage of
that
so the question I have is Dave has
always said hey put up to your company
match
in your 401k then go outside and match
out your Roth and then go back into your
401k to get to your 15 percent
my question is should I put my total 15
percent
into my Roth 401k instead of going
outside of my raw that's an option and
that's actually what me and my wife have
done because it's a Roth option so that
advice the match beats rothbeast
traditional is what you're talking about
and because you have Roth options in the
401K you don't have to deal with any
traditional options and so if you go
beyond the 15 with your employer you
could then put some into that Roth IRA
if if your income would exceed that now
there are income limits with the Roth
IRA there are not income limits with the
Roth 401k
okay so you'd probably get is that are
you going to hit the max limit this year
yes that's exciting so anything beyond
that
um I think with 140 look into it with
the limits are for this year you may
still be able to contribute to a Roth
IRA I'm not sure about that
okay but if not you could still
contribute to the traditional IRA to
finish out that 15 percent
okay sounds good thank you very much you
got it man awesome thanks for your call
I appreciate that I think a lot of
people wonder about that you know they
they're not sure how to invest their
money so the rule generally would be
match beats Roth beats traditional but
in his case he had the match in the same
place that he had his Roth benefit
through his uh 401K so if you don't have
a Roth 401k option you just have
traditional through your employer we
would say get the match if there is one
then go fully fund a Roth IRA outside of
your employer and then you can go back
to your traditional 401k and finish out
the 15 but if you've got the raw 401K
gear the point here is to get the tax
advantage uh growth now what about
George if you exceed the limits for
doing a Roth IRA what would you say to
those folks so that would be if you have
a if you have a real high income and you
are above those limits you still have
other options number one an HSA is a
great place to Sock away money for
retirement it can actually become a
retirement account so if you Max that
out number one you get the tax benefit
it'll be deducted and when you're I
believe 65 it kind of becomes like a
traditional 401k account that's right it
does I love that and of course you can
use that money towards qualified medical
expenses and get the full tax benefit
there so that's an option there's also
taxable brokerage account outside of
retirement uh which means you're not
getting any real tax benefits but that
money is going to get the power of
compound interest yep I love it very
very cool let's take another call let's
see what Thomas is talking about in
Kansas City what's going on Thomas how
can we help today
hey how y'all doing doing good
yeah so my wife and I we don't have any
debt except for our house
um
we I'm kind of a spreadsheet nerd so
I've got like a budget and I've got a
bunch of formulas all set up so
um based on my projections and how much
money we're able to put towards the
principal we should have it paid off
within three and a half years nice yeah
pretty exciting so but my question is
um we don't have any money in for
retirement
um so I know I think part of the program
is you start you get all your debt paid
off except the house then you start
putting 50 towards 401k or retirement
accounts and then then you start working
on paying off the house I think is the
process so I'm kind of jumping the gun
doing the house part first yeah because
yeah so I guess my question is like is
that is that fine because once some we
have the house paid off then I'm like
all right let's just start piling money
into retirement and setting money aside
to like get like a rental house like
that's kind of what I'm thinking to do
so right now you're working your own
plan which is the Thomas plan and if if
that's what you want to do that's cool
but since you called us you know we we
work things through a series of baby
steps and you were close to it
um the first for those of you listening
and also for you Thomas the first step
is baby step one thousand dollars saved
then baby step two you're paying off all
of your debt except the mortgage uh
using the debt snowball and then after
that we don't go to investing we go to
baby step three which is making sure we
have three to six months
um emergency fund saved so that we're
not using our investments as an
emergency fund and then after that baby
step four Thomas is when we start
investing 15 so you are kind of doing
this thing you gotta get all rigged a
little bit and do it your own way I
would really urge you and suggest to use
it the correct way because we know that
this is the plan that has helped
millions of people uh build wealth uh
George is one of those people and
there's there's method to the madness uh
we want to make sure we have that
savings first because when folks don't
have savings their 401K becomes their
savings and that's a horrible place to
be because you're hit with penalties and
you're hit with fees
um paying off the home before you have
the rest of your debt paid off also not
a great idea so there's a reason that
this works the way that it works
um does that kind of answer some of your
questions or give you peace about it
yeah no it does and yeah I forgot to
mention we do have the about three to
six months of money saved up as well so
I I forgot to mention that we do have
that stuff but yeah it's just I've got
the retirement account and then the
house payment kind of fled the day yeah
and and let me also encourage you in
this way you know when it comes to your
retirement you want that compound
interest to work for you for as long as
possible you know the time is the key on
that so no I would not pay off the
mortgage first because that's time that
you could have spent in the market that
you're now sacrificing does that make
sense
yeah it does and that's kind of what I
was how old are you two
uh I'm 31 she's 32. you got plenty of
time but you got to get started today
turn that thing on 15 household income
into retirement accounts and whatever's
left we can start throwing out that
mortgage you know George it's funny I
hear people calling all the time and and
they're calling us but they they're
doing what Dave would call Ish right
they're familiar with the baby steps
maybe they've been listening but they've
kind of developed their own well it's
their own style it's like well I'll just
take a little bit of that I'm gonna grab
some crab rangoon over here you know but
the problem with that is you don't get
results you get ish results that's right
and what's it based off of because you
don't have a track record 10 million
people doing this and becoming baby
steps millionaires I mean that's enough
social proof for me okay because I was
an idiot who thought my plan was gonna
somehow be better than that I know
that's right I would rather go with the
proven track record a plan that has
helped millions of people not just
myself but my guy George camel over here
build wealth become millionaire status
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
thank you
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey show my
name is Jade warshaw I am your host
today along with my buddy George
Campbell and uh we want you guys to give
us a call we want to discuss the things
that are important to you today so give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five and uh
just before the break George and I were
we were having some some pretty
interesting conversation heated
discussions heated discussion George I
felt like you were losing your temper
there I tend to do that over trivial
things so here's what happened we just
released a brand new episode of smart
money happy hour which Rachel Cruz and I
host and the entire episode is about
junk fees and so the title is there's a
fee for that and we're over it and so we
just get we're getting heated and in
debates about should there be fees for
some of this stuff so I want to run it
by you Jade run it by our audience and
you guys respond in your cars or your
homes where whatever you're listening so
for example Postmates which is food
delivery they add delivery fee and
charges more if you want your food
delivered without additional stops which
who's like yeah you can stop three times
I'll take my food cold that's fine I
don't trust these places anyway well
I've seen video like someone ate a piece
of my pizza they took some of my fries
they took them yes they did think about
it you go through the drive through if
you go and get McDonald's fries just for
your family of course you're dipping in
the bag having a couple of cream fries
you're telling me that these folks are
going to Chick-fil-A
many reasons why I don't use these
Services because I have trust issues oh
they're they're eating the fries and
they got Dirty Fingers I'm telling you
that right now I don't know where those
fingers have been okay here's one that I
actually agree with Uber and Lyft now
have a wait time fee so here's the deal
there's a charging curve If a driver has
to wait for you more than two minutes
upon pickup that's fine as long as I get
to charge a fee when I have to wait for
them oh but see that's out of there like
what if they hit traffic no because
George here's the thing you're they're
hustling you're deciding every time
you're like am I going to do Uber or
Lyft right is it I always do the quote
with them both and see who's cheaper but
that's the thing you pick the one that's
cheaper and maybe the time is less and
then you see you look in the little the
little car is flipping right to left I'm
so cheap I'll choose the option that's
like hey if you wait 14 extra minutes
we'll give you three dollars off I'm
like dumb I'm willing to wait look I
hate it when it they tell me it's gonna
take 15 minutes and before I know it
I've been waiting 20 minutes so as long
as I can charge
the same way they charge wow I'm just
trying to be fair George well how about
this one Airbnb this one grinds my gears
they'll add on everything from cleaning
fees to cancellation fees to service
fees to Insurance packages to where I
just stay at hotels now I just truly
don't do Airbnb unless we have a big
group of people and we all want to be in
a house together now see these charges
kind of make sense to me because I'm
like okay
I clean it I want to know that if the
place costs a hundred dollars a night
and you're charging me a 250 cleaning
fee it just doesn't make sense to stay
there but can I also say I feel like
when people go to airbnbs it's like
we're wilding out like we're we're going
hard like there's parties money is is
not is not an issue for Judd when she's
at an interview no no not me
I was like you get a house with your
friends like but here's the issue I
don't know I feel like there's a lot of
things that can go be destroyed here's
the Airbnb house they're going to charge
you 250 for the cleaning fee but they're
still going to be like but also I need
you to strip the sheets start a load of
laundry start the dishwasher I need you
to feed that the lawn needs to be mowed
and there's a creaky door if you could
take some WD-40 to that on your way out
that'd be great
I'm out so okay I see I see yeah and uh
travel is a big one there's a lot of
fees in the travel world
and with you know some of these Frontier
and spirit the flights are like four
dollars but then they'll nickel and dime
you and be like oh you wanted to breathe
it's an extra five dollars if you want
to breathe sorry I hate that look I go
can I say spirit I can say it so there's
a airline that is called Spirit you just
said it guys it is not worth it it is
like a Greyhound bus in the skies
I will Sky Bus I once went on one and
there was graffiti you know how like in
the 8th grade bathroom there's like you
know
people just write stuff people the seats
had graffiti on it and I'm like is this
what I paid 20 an extra 25 to have my
seat fee plus my bag fee and I gotta pay
for a water are you kidding me oh it's
it's out of control which you know I'm a
Southwest fan they just went through
this whole debacle but they do give you
two bags for free that's true but then I
gotta fight over my seat I don't want to
have to bite somebody's forearm to get
my seat I'm not big enough to intimidate
anyone into not sitting next to me I'm
Prime I'm Prime bait you know if I'm
sitting in a seat they're like I'm
sitting next to that guy because you
know I got the armrest George all you
got to do is put your glasses on the end
of your nose and look down your nose I
puff up like a blowfish when I'm in a
seat on Southwest I'm taking up as much
space as I can I'm mean mugging them I
might start coughing yes that's all you
have to do all you have to do is start
coughing and sneezing nobody's gonna sit
next to you well the next VJ this is a
new one AMC movie theaters have now
added variable pricing called sight line
seating so uh if you want to have a seat
that's not in the front row you might
pay an extra two bucks to get that Prime
seat
okay I don't like that no I'm treating
it like a concert
yeah it's not I'm not going to see
Taylor Swift the screen's plenty big I
just have a hard time whenever something
has been the same forever
like it's always been like that you've
done nothing new and now you're just
charging for something that's always
been does that make sense sure like what
did you guys add that is of value you've
just decided hey these front row seats
have always been here let's charge more
I it's unfair well and companies can
just do it and obviously it makes their
bottom line look better increases their
profits and uh concerts and games this
happens a lot with these major events
these processing fees StubHub is one of
them they add 15 to 20 in service fees
on top of the ticket costs Ticketmaster
these people are the worst service fee
delivery fee taxes venue fee they start
blaming the clients and the artists and
uh there's non-refundable fees uh as
well and I hate that and specifically
this one I don't like because I feel
like the music industry they're putting
they're putting the Dollar on us when
y'all need to just figure out how to get
these musicians the money that they
deserve for their streams for their
shows anymore yeah that's what happens I
don't well I am going to see Kenny
Loggins here in a minute wow still
touring okay this is his how old is he
this is his last tour he's got to be in
his 70s how do we know it's not like a
weekend at Bernie situation they just
got them up there like a Chuck E cheese
animatronic he he can still sing this is
his last one though I cannot wait Kenny
Loggins I love it I like this next part
George okay this is fees that we we want
to bring to life that should be a thing
so these are your pet peeves that you
wish you could charge people for okay
you have any of these uh yes I have some
but I want you to say this first one
that really gets to me a fee for people
who say supposedly instead of supposedly
yes it's nuanced but they're the same
people who say espresso instead of
espresso now you want to see me give
somebody eye Jammy real quick is when
they say espresso it's like right in the
eye it's not express it's espresso
espresso people uh how about this one a
fee for people who aggressively lean
their seat all the way back on airplanes
these people I saw one where a girl
threw all of her hair to the seat behind
her so that it wasn't up against her
seat look if if you've never been hit in
the eye with somebody's hair when they
flip their hair that is number one it's
painful it's an assault You Gotta Be You
Gotta know who's around you when you do
that okay what's your fee what's your
pet peeve fee okay I'm gonna say this
and then I'm gonna be the worst offender
but when people say the word like every
other word I mean like George is kind of
like I mean I was just like going over
here and like my money like it's like a
square jar I think I just made four
dollars from you just doing it it's
terrible the like jar it starts out with
your friends and see how much money you
make now there are some fees that I
think are fair I don't want to just put
fees you know
um one is you know valet parking yeah
that's a convenience yes especially at
the airport there was one though that's
like local you know we live in the
suburbs out here and this restaurant had
a huge parking lot it's right there I
Can Go The Parking Spot is three feet
from where I am and they want to go take
my car to move it three feet to charge
me wow and I'll do the self Park yeah so
that's one that's legit you know at the
airport though valet will change your
life not if you're in baby step two
though I've never done ballet at an
airport what George with your bougie
self let me tell you I know get get on
it because this is the child of
immigrants okay I do the like the hotel
parking and take the shuttle so that I
can pay Seven dollars a day instead of
the 24 a day
so that's me there's some things I am
unwilling to pay a fee for I get that
some isn't it true sometimes twenty
dollars seems like nothing and then
sometimes twenty dollars feels like the
most expensive thing in the world you're
like 20. it's the principal Jade well
hey if you want to hear more about this
Rachel Cruz and I have a great time
talking about it on the latest episode
of smart money happy hour you can listen
to it you can watch it now we can see
our reactions on our YouTube channel
smart money happy hour we'll link it in
the show notes and put in the YouTube
description for you all let us know what
you think add in your fees you're the
most angry about in the comments let's
get angry together start a revolution
against fees I love it I love it this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show my
name is Jade warshaw I'm joined Today by
George Campbell and we're taking calls
about your life your money the things
that are concerning you the things that
are keeping you up at night anything
that's on your mind we're here to talk
about it today you can give us a call
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five and let me tell
you something if you're a new listener
and you want to dive deeper into the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button you may hear us talk
about things all the time like the baby
steps or you know a rule about this or a
rule about that or we use the jargon you
know and we we think that you all know
the answer but if you're like what are
they talking about this is the thing for
you to do we'll help you figure out the
best next step for you on your financial
Journey there's lots of resources there
for you guys to understand what this is
all about these baby steps all of this
it's based on exactly where you're at
today so it's super helpful so head over
to ramsesolutions.com and click get
started
all right George let's go ahead and take
some calls I think we've got several on
the board here we got Logan from Kansas
City what's going on Logan how can we
help today
hey guys yeah thanks for taking the call
um so basically it's just kind of a
housing market question
um uh here's the the scenario um my wife
and I own a house and we currently rent
the upstairs for about 1100 a month the
mortgage is only 7.90 on the home and we
live in the basement pretty much for
free uh by doing that well just kind of
share the kitchen and the laundry room
and the the common spaces but
everybody's got their own space and uh
and we're good
um the the offside to that is that you
know we have to go through a garage to
get to the kitchen and you know we don't
really have our own kitchen shared space
and so it would be nice to have our own
space given that we're married
um so the scenario would be you know
looking at potentially purchasing
another home and turning this into a
full-fledged rental
um if we did that we'd probably be able
to get around 1600 a month for the
property so that'd be an additional 800
of cash flow not including all the
expenses that go along with that but um
so yeah we're considering buying a
property getting some of our own space
and then turning this into rental
um what's what's your guys's thoughts
there so would you buy another property
near near that property
yes yeah uh still same KC metro area and
would you do that with cash
unfortunately no
um yeah our situation right now would be
probably a three percent down situation
um live in it and and kind of represent
conventional
um
well there's there's a lot of risk there
when you're carrying two mortgages now
and if one thing goes wrong with this
plan that looks great on paper it leaves
you guys in a real precarious situation
so that's my big worry with this and we
always recommend we love real estate we
love rental property but we only
recommend doing that once you have a
primary residence paid for and you buy
the next one in cash your investment
property which I know sounds like well
that's years away yes but also what lets
you walk into this with a lot of peace
that's a good point
okay because I mean the spread right now
you're making is about what 300 bucks
and that's without anything going wrong
something need to be replaced repairs
whatever else happens so you're making
about three grand off this deal so it's
not like it's changing your life even to
rent out the upstairs
right so to me is it if you said hey
I'll give you a three grand pay cut but
you get to go through your house freely
I'm taking that deal
what would you make if you sold the
house
sold the sold the house that you're in
now and purchased something that makes
sense for you and your wife you've got
your privacy you've got your own kitchen
you've got your own space what would
that look like
um so yeah we've got a little over 20
into the home
um it might be worth around 200
um so let's see I owe 110 on it so we'd
probably be able to walk away with uh 80
80 000 ish maybe and then put that down
payment towards something something that
we really wanted and really liked what's
your household income
um we we average probably around 70
together
okay so how quickly could you pay off
your mortgage at the current residence
yeah that's a great Point um I'm not
entirely sure I've not done the math on
that but if we can I mean we're probably
around uh 1500 a month as far as what we
can save
um so that would allow us to kind of put
uh that much down on on anything else
per month did you guys have any other
debt like that
uh we do not we're both we're both debt
free we've got some Investments both of
us that are in the stock market and I've
actually kind of paused mine
um just for the time being but I do need
to get those back up and running again
as well
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund
we do yes okay yeah I'd get those
Investments back up to 15 whatever's
left start throwing it at the house and
if you just don't want to rent her
anymore there's nothing wrong with
saying we're just not going to make this
this amount of profit and we're going to
have our life back and we'll be back in
the real estate investing game one day
but that day's not today would you keep
that same house as your personal
residence without the renter or does it
not make sense would you would you move
into something different
no yeah I think I think the house we're
in now currently makes a lot of sense
um so it may make the most sense to just
take it over for ourselves and and kind
of then you know start snowballing and
saving and getting that ball rolling and
like you said
um get this paid off and and then
purchase the next rental property yeah
so you've got a lot of options there the
option that you don't have is to have
two mortgages because that right there
is a recipe uh for disaster three
percent down and having no equity in
that thing and it's just that scares the
crap out of me absolutely we've got time
to take one more call this is Connor
from Austin Texas let's make it pretty
quick Connor let us go let us know how
we can help you
yeah of course thanks y'all for taking
the call so my question is around I am
starting a new job and I had a 401k
match for four percent of my previous
employer so I have a 401k this new
employer doesn't offer a whole okay
until the first year but then it's a six
percent match so I'm just wondering what
to do with my old employer 401K in the
meantime aha so it's still sitting with
the old employer
it is and it's a traditional 401k or
Roth
it's so traditional but there was uh
okay so I would just do a direct
rollover to a traditional IRA that's
going to give you the most control
flexibility and investment options
okay got it would I be able to roll that
over to my employer 401K after the year
is that once I'm eligible depending on
your employer's 401K you may be able to
roll it in there but personally I would
rather have full control of it by
putting it into an IRA which is one of
the benefits of leaving an employer you
have the ability to move it into an IRA
okay got it and then when I'm eligible
for my employer's problem okay just
start from scratch and contribute to
that yes do you have any debt
I have a solar panel on my house kind of
my stupid tax if you will but outside of
that no no well here's a plan uh before
you invest any more dollars what if we
could get that solar panel paid off
before the 401K benefit kicks in
that is something I've thought about and
something that I've could do this year
and then just start recontributing again
to that full okay do you have any
savings
I do have about 6 500. okay and what's
left on the solar panel loan
about 29 000 or something during the
minimum payments okay so we could take
five grand from your savings throw it at
the solar panel alone and and get about
the business of paying it off could you
pay it off within the year with your
income
I've switched to a commission-based job
but I'm thinking some commission I
should be able to pay it off outright
within a year love it well commission's
great because you can just go kill stuff
and drag it home and bust your butt so
that would be my goal and I think that'd
be really cool if you could have a three
to six months emergency fund with no
debt and be ready to invest when that
one-year benefit kicks in for the 401K I
love that idea I feel like that's the
way to go I like having just something
dangling in front of me I think as
humans we need that behaviorally yes
just to stay motivated and so you know
when we were paying off our house I said
I'm not going to upgrade my my 09 Civic
with a bumper hanging off until I pay
off the house and absolutely it's so
much more rewarding at that point I mean
I think that's the way that the the baby
steps are designed right you know I say
it all the time I feel like one and two
you're just like you're just busting it
and you cannot wait because all the
money that you're giving it's to
somebody else you're paying off debt
you're giving them the money and then
it's like but if I could just get to
baby step three and I get to pocket
everything right I feel like the whole
thing is designed that way then it's
like oh I finally get to start investing
it's like you've waited for that moment
so it's all about like you said that
carrot dangling in front of you and when
you start to be able to enjoy those
moments it makes it even more sweet we
say personal finances it's only 20 head
knowledge it's 80 Behavior yes it's
psychology yes it's not about the math
and once you get a hold of that it
changes you on top of changing your
money absolutely because most people
that you talk to they know that they
know the right thing to do yes I'm
supposed to save money yes debt is bad
credit cards are bad but they don't do
what it takes it's the behavior that
makes the difference that does it for
today's show be sure to join us next
time and remember this when it comes to
changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but
please don't tell me that you can't With
God all things are possible
guys it's Jay it's Jay if you love the
show and want
and want to dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way just go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm your host Jade
warshaw and I am joined by the wonderful
illustrious wow George Campbell I know
you like when I say illustrious makes me
it's it's a Timeless adjective it
definitely is and we're here to take
calls about your life and your money
George he he is an expert on investing
Insurance all sorts of things so kind
I'll help you with the baby steps I'll
help you get out of debt I'll help you
stay motivated give us a call today the
number Jade I will say the number first
because we got to get the calls on the
board but I I got something to talk
about okay
what do you got to say well I had to ask
you just hosted the record-breaking
virtual Financial Peace University class
yesterday and I just wanted to know how
it went that's right yeah yes George is
correct uh we did we we started uh a
Financial Peace University class with
myself leading the first class was last
night George we had
1081 people sign up for this class can
you believe it that's wild unbelievable
it was great and this is like a boot
camp version you're doing in five weeks
meeting twice a week correct wow yes
we're going super speed people are
changing their lives this like the stuff
it really works okay so it's too late to
sign up for yours but it's not too late
to sign up for a class it won't it may
not be as great as Jades but that's a
high bar I mean look it's gonna be great
we had to close off this class because
we didn't want that many folks you know
it's got to be helpful for you guys so
we don't want to go past a thousand but
uh yeah you can't get in mind but please
please please we have amazing
coordinators all over the country who
who help us run these things and man
they're the arms and feet of this place
we so appreciate them that's right and
you can do the Financial Peace
University class in person like in small
groups there's different groups that
meet all around the country or if you're
like I'm not trying to be around folks I
like staying in my house then you can do
you got seven kids and it's hard to get
out you can still do it yeah you can do
the virtual version so whatever you do
this is your year to change your
finances this is your year to change
your life I was talking to the folks
earlier today and a guy asked me he said
what do you do how do you stay motivated
I'm like you just have to want to change
the pain of staying the same has to be
greater than the pain of changing you've
got to be like I can't live like this
anymore something's got to give
Something's Gotta shake and that's when
you sign up for Financial Peace
University and that's when you start
listening to shows like the Ramsay show
if you're walking through this good on
you for tuning into a show like this to
stay motivated and let me tell you
something uh if you like this show if
this show has changed your life please
share it with somebody alright share the
share the good news with somebody who is
out there broke and struggling because
they need this too if you're listening
on YouTube uh subscribe subscribe to the
show it's great for you it's great for
us it kicks it up in the algorithm so
more people see it and it puts it top of
mind for you as well so you can continue
to consume this and also leave a review
we would love if you wrote something
nice about the show whether it's on the
podcast whether it's on YouTube say
something nice so that all the haters
out there sipping on that haterade will
shut it up all right that's right I know
that's right so let's take a couple of
calls here we got Roslyn over here in
Richmond Virginia hey I have family in
Richmond Virginia what's going on Roslyn
hi can you hear me I can hi hi Jane yeah
George thanks for taking my call
I'm calling because I came across Dave
Ramsey in January 2022 last year really
improved my life got the dead out the
way and everything
um but of course I made a lot of bad
decisions before but I want to buy a
home by the end of this year and uh
y'all kind of say Okay manual
underwriting and well basically to get
rid of your credit score
um well I was wondering if that's really
the good strategy for me because in my
past I have a foreclosure so I don't
want to make things harder for myself
um if I were to have no credit score
which is actually improved now because
I've been going through a lot of things
being off that and everything so
um what do you think about that I mean
I'm not sure it kind of makes me kind of
nervous to I'm not using the credit
cards but they still are you know online
report and uh so how long ago was the
foreclosure
2016 and it's coming up on seven years
on September this year so it'll get
cleared from your history
does it really because I don't well from
your report it may always be on your
history but as far as if you pull the
report it's not going to affect your
chances of you know getting a mortgage
and it depends on what you did you know
what was this do you know what kind of
bankruptcy this was
well it's the one where I had to pay a
lot of money back it took money on my
check so it was a payment plan that went
on
um yeah with parent plan and um I paid a
lot of money out of my check that went
on for a year like five years big four
years something like that well generally
you've got to wait four years after
bankruptcy to be able to apply for you
know conventional mortgage loan and it
sounds like you're not at a a place to
be a homeowner based on what you've told
us because you still have some debt
hanging around how much debt do you have
left no no I have no debt okay here
because when I I came across stage and I
uh January and I did everything I mean
he used to say this thing about you know
the new home the home mortgage paid off
is better than BMW yeah so anyway I got
rid of my BMW and the great big payment
I got a Toyota I mean I wiped that off
very good incident loan pay the credit
cards and so now I all I have is um I
have an apartment I've been living here
like you know for like just double the
years
um I'm older I I I like the idea of one
day not having to pay for roof over my
head so that of course
so I would really like to go on and
purchase a home I have saved so far like
um
say minus my emergency fund which is 25
000 so I have an extra forty thousand
and I know I can have another 45 by the
end of the year awesome so you'd have 85
000 to put down
yes very good hey can I just hold off
you're amazing very good you had a
messed up past with this money but you
have totally turned it around and I'm
just so proud of you
that's incredible God I thank God for
finding him because it is very late but
still it's better than never yes very
good very good have you contacted like
Churchill Mortgage and said hey I went
through this foreclosure seven years ago
here's where I'm at I have I'll have
this much down by the end of the year
have you kind of looked into it and done
some homework
no I I didn't even know if that was
something that was that was a good
strategy I don't know actually just go
on the normal
it'll help you what's your credit score
right now
um right now it's 7 30. okay around 70
and based on your numbers if you're
walking in with a 730 credit score and
you've got 85 000 to put down you know
obviously depending on the house and
your income I don't see why they they
wouldn't approve you for a loan but
still do some homework call our friends
at Churchill Mortgage and they'll walk
you through the process and they'll
explain to you exactly what you'll need
to do in order to become a homeowner and
we are cheering you on man along the way
what a journey that just goes to show
your past does not have to be your
future this woman went ahead and changed
her whole life yet again another thing
that proves this plan works if you work
it she went from bankruptcy to now 40 to
all the excuses and she said I'm gonna
get back up I'm doing this thing love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsay show my
name is Jade warshaw your host and I'm
here with George Campbell give us a call
today the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and if you're
planning to move soon we know that it
can be expensive I know firsthand
because your girl just moved from South
Florida here to Tennessee but I've got
great news for you our studio sponsor
PODS moving and storage wants to help
someone move for free just get a quote
at pods.com Ramsay between February 20th
and March 3rd so you got two more days
to do this deal and enter to win it's
really that simple matter of fact my
buddy called me the other day they were
like I entered the PODS moving storage
thing I was like yes one listener will
get a free move valued up to five
thousand dollars and ten thousand
dollars in Cold Hard Cash that's what
I'm talking about if you're following
the math that's a total value George of
15. 15 smack 15 000 smackers I wish I
was eligible I know right man not
foreign so kind to them look pods just
made moving that much easier George with
flexibility that you need the control
that you want and customer service can
we just take a moment for customers
there's an oxymoron in today's world I
know right we're not used to it pause is
known for it they are and if you're
looking for a company that is going to
help you on your moving uh on your move
on your terms I love that then it's pods
pods is the only Ramsay trusted moving
provider that's out there so go to
pods.com Ramsay to enter for your free
chance to win this free move and you get
the ten thousand dollars in cash so
today go onto pods.com
Ramsay I love it I love it in George we
got a question of the day here let's
take a look at this question of the day
it comes from Katie
North Dakota here's what she says once I
become debt free and cut up all my
credit cards will this hurt my credit
score lower credit scores mean higher
interest rates on the house I would like
to buy in the future or do you recommend
saving for a house with cash even though
that might take a long time this is a
great question because the credit score
industry is so confusing oh yeah and
they're very they they keep it with lock
and key and so there are a few things we
know about how the credit score is made
up but yes canceling your card could
mean that your credit score takes a dip
yeah because that makes sense you pay
off your debt and close your accounts
and they go not okay with us well I mean
think about it the whole credit score is
based on your relationship with debt
right how much debt you have how long
have you had the debt you know what's
your debt to income we're like that
yeah payment history is the biggest one
35 of your scores that's the factor
amounts owed is 30 length of credit
history another 15 new credit 10 credit
mix the variety of credit another 10 and
so it's all having to do with how much
you play kissy face with the bank man
I'm not doing it I I'll be the first to
tell you guys when we canceled our
credit cards and the ones that were in
my name uh yeah my credit score took a
dip I'll be honest my credit score was
not great to begin with it was probably
like 6 30 or something like that and
yeah it went down and then it had a
period of time where it just kind of
stayed the same and did nothing but let
me tell you something George as soon as
that last debt was paid off it went down
to zero
that's right so what we're talking about
here uh is not a tanking of your credit
score it means your credit score becomes
invisible or indeterminable so six to 12
months after you pay off all your debt
you close all those accounts six to 12
months later that score disappears yep
and here's the good news once you cut up
your cards and become completely debt
free you're not out of the woods you got
to have a fully funded emergency fund
and start saving up the down payment and
so you actually don't need uh the credit
score for that process if you go through
manual under yes come on and tell them
George so manual underwriting is a
little known fact I did a quick clip
from the show went viral on social media
and people think oh I can get around the
system I have a terrible score but I can
still get a no score alone no no it's in
the name no score loan and Churchill
Mortgage is the number one lender in the
country that does these yeah and so that
you know if you go through Churchill
Mortgage for an example and you want
manual underwriting you gotta have no
credit score at all to do these manual
underwriting no score loans
which means you're completely debt free
you've got to have a good down payment
you know let's say minimum 10 down and
you go you got to do the 15-year which I
know is crazy in today's culture it's
worth it but if you do those things hear
me say this you will have the same exact
interest rate as someone with excellent
credit that's and I verified this with
our friends at Churchill I've had
multiple discussions we ran numbers
where we actually showed people your
quotes for your mortgages yeah and they
found if you do 10 down on a 15-year
fixed with a good you know your your
numbers all check out your W-2s are
there your income is there yep you've
got proof of 12 months of rental history
verific verified by a landlord or even
your parents and you have other utility
bills you've been paying on time for 12
months your insurance premiums your cell
phone bills your utility bills all of
that counts towards this financial
picture yeah to where a real person says
you are approved for the mortgage at a
great rate and let me can I just say
because I know somebody regardless of
how well and how eloquently George just
described that the there's still
somebody sitting out there going
um I don't know and can I just tell you
I was that person when Sam and I were
going through the baby steps you know we
were like there were some things that I
was like I know Dave is saying this I
know George and Rachel and all them are
saying this but can it really be true
I'm telling you I'm sitting in the seat
telling you it works credit score went
to zero and I was like oh I was excited
but I was a little bit nervous and then
I did what they told me to do we went to
Churchill Mortgage Jeff Green shout out
to Jeffrey green at Churchill Mortgage
he walked us through the process and
here's the thing it's even easier if
you've got like a standard nine to five
job because it's easy to show you know
all the records and everything they want
to show but as a small business owner it
still worked the proof is in the pudding
I'm sitting here telling you and I've
done the same I went through this
process and the crazy part is people
still commented going BS and I went what
part of this do you not understand what
I just told you I did it and then here's
the frustrating part Jade people start
pop it in the comments going well yeah
look at that guy's skin color of course
he got approved for a mortgage what
what so Jay can you verify uh look the
melanin is real and your girl's got a
house and she got it on a zero credit
score now here's the thing why do you
want to be right so bad that's what I
want to know why do you want to be right
that you cannot buy a home with a zero
credit score what is that getting you
what is it getting you I kind of like
the fact that we live in a world where
you don't have to bow down to the credit
gods and there's still a way for you to
make a way without borrowing money from
credit why are you mad about that I'm
mad y'all got me mad we got a riled up
it's so true Jade we can Rise Above This
broken system yes and people just go
because they've never done it and
because there's so much baggage there's
so much shame there's so much crap that
they've had to deal with financially
they just go well that might work for
them but it's not going to work for me
but what's crazy about our plan is it
works every time you work it and when
you become completely debt free with an
emergency fund and you're patient you
save up that down payment you make the
sacrifices you need to make you can
become a homeowner without a score yeah
regardless of your skin color and where
you came from and all the baggage that
you come to the door with you can win
financially but it starts when you put
all that baggage aside and say I'm gonna
win in spite of all that boom George and
here's the thing here's the thing if you
want to play with debt if you want to go
and do the credit card deal so you want
to do the credit card shuffle you want
to play with assets and liabilities and
leverage and do go ahead and go on and
do that and get yourself a 800 credit
score and go buy your house and have
trouble sleeping at night but for the
rest of us as for me and my house as for
me in my house we are not going to serve
these FICO Gods we are not going to do
it we are going to have our own money
and our own account doing our own thing
and if you want to be mad about it you
go ahead and be mad all day because
we're going to be laughing all the way
to the bank and we ain't mad about it
that's right we want to share the good
news so and with this credit score stuff
even aside from home ownership people go
well Jade your insurance rates are going
to be terrible and how are you going to
rent a car and a hotel listen I have
lived my life without the credit score
using a debit card yep and I even
checked I checked every major rental car
companies policies they all have a debit
card policy yes they do and yes you
might have a slight slightly higher
deposit yeah you got to have a little
money in your account but aside from
that it wasn't much different than a
normal process no and the same goes for
pretty much everything renting you know
renting an Airbnb getting a hotel yeah
and car loans that's a big one people
say well Jade how am I going to get a
car loan you don't you don't get it you
pay cash even fraud you know people have
said well you got to have a credit card
what if you have fraud I'm like well
number one I got Xander to cover that
and two anytime I've ever had fraud on
my account they've given me the money
back it's the same thing you don't need
credit cards that's a lie I'm done with
those questions come at me FICO come at
me bro that's what I'm talking about
when it comes to credit George and Jade
warshaw are not playing George Campbell
and Jade warshaw we do not have the same
last name hashtag debitlife I know
that's right we got that debt free
lifestyle and we want that for you as
well this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
what's up guys you're listening to the
Ramsey Show I'm Jade warshaw joined by
George camel we're taking your calls
today so give us a call uh the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're willing to discuss whatever
it is that you guys want to discuss as
it relates to your life and your money
we're going to take a call from Brett in
Kansas City second one from Kansas City
today what's going on Brett
yeah so
um I was calling because
cuz you know like the the Ramsey Clan
and principles and everything and we've
been debt free since uh since we were
first married all the way until uh we
got our first mortgage
um but we did incur some debt at the
beginning of last year because my wife
uh had our first baby and had to make
some uh for some medical reasons we
encourage some medical debt over the
course of the Year okay
um but from January to the end of last
year we managed to get all of that you
know paid off or settled
um and then I think it was about oh I
don't know halfway through the year we
got into baby step three and have just
kind of got stuck there where it feels
like we accumulated that we accumulated
about half of our goal for the emergency
fund
um and then it just feels like we've
stalled out because and I feel I don't
know if it's a budgeting problem I have
but it just feels like every time so
like every time a car breaks a little
bit or some little thing comes up we're
always dipping into the emergency fund
and so I've just been getting frustrated
because we haven't I thought we'd be
closer in making more ground on the goal
and it really just feels like we've been
slipping for the past couple months yeah
and I'm trying to figure that out can I
ask a couple of background questions
just to kind of get an idea how much
debt did you guys pay off
so
um like I said it was kind of a mix of
paying it off and also settling with the
different medical establishments we had
to work through but we ended up getting
rid of about eight thousand dollars in
debt
okay and uh because you told me that
you've been kind of listening to this
for five years and that you guys got
debt free early on and then you had the
yeah yeah we didn't have any debt when
we were married and we we bought two
cars with cash in that time okay and you
know got our we did get our first house
that was the first debt we incurred as a
couple was getting our mortgage okay um
what's your household income
uh it's about
we're kind of in between about I think
40 and 45
000 each year
um I'm a contractor single income
household my wife is stay at home okay
so what I want to encourage you is from
this point on is really do these baby
steps in order because I think you kind
of got out of order you guys did some of
the debt then you bought a house and
then you know you kind of did your own
thing and I think that's why it's taking
you a while now with this baby step
three it's gonna take as long as you let
it take you know and so the big key for
this is a budget and it kind of sounds
like you said that you're using a budget
but it doesn't sound like you guys are
are living you know swearing by this
thing it sounds like it's kind of there
and maybe you follow it and maybe you
don't am I am I wrong or am I right
um a little bit of both so one of the
struggles for us is my income does like
week to week fluctuates quite a bit
being in Contracting you know sometimes
there's it feels like there's way more
than enough on a week and then there's
another you know week things come up
kind of short so right we've uh and I
don't know what the best practices are
for budgeting on a on a you know an
income that kind of fluctuates like that
but well you wanna you wanna budget
based on your your lowest possible month
right so if you look back on the last
six to eight months and you say okay
like on average this this has been my
lowest month then I start the budget
based on that and pay as much as you can
and then all the extra money that money
goes towards you know the gravy of the
wants within the budget so with a
regular income you would start with the
most important things your four walls
food utility housing Transportation then
beyond that if there's more money that
month we start moving on the list of
things we got to take care of you know
if you need to upgrade you know the baby
needs some new clothes or whatever it is
and then at the very tail end is the
luxuries and you may not have room for
those right now uh with your income and
where you guys are at so how much money
do you have in baby step three in that
emergency fund right now
um as of right now I think we have about
I think it's about 2 800 right now and
what's your goal started out the goal is
uh ten thousand okay okay good goal so
we're we're about seven thousand dollars
shy and if you can you pick up extra
work as a contractor
um I do a few side jobs uh here and
there so I do most of my work
exclusively through uh through one guy
but I'm still considered independent
um but I do some side jobs on my own and
I am also a licensed Barber I Barber on
the side as a side hustle cool and maybe
there's something your wife can do too
yeah we've been trying to figure that
she does occasionally uh do a little bit
of substitute teaching here's the thing
here's the thing you guys if you're
wandering through this thing is going to
take forever and it kind of I'm not
trying to get on you but it sounds like
you guys are kind of like uh if it works
we'll do it you know if she feels like
it she'll do it we try to go over here
and do it you've got to decide and I
know this is not baby step two but baby
step three is equally important because
you have seen that if you don't have
this baby step in order and you don't
have this emergency fund there what
happens you end up going back into debt
so you've got to get this done and
honestly it's up to you guys how quickly
you want to make this thing go this can
uh span out another year and a year and
a half where you guys can knock this out
in the next several months and have that
uh that ten thousand dollars saved so
it's truly truly truly up to you Brett
all right George well I'm making you
know that's about 20 bucks an hour if
you're making 40 Grand a year yeah and
I'm going he's a contractor he's good
with his hands I'm gonna go be a
handyman on the the side hang on I know
this because I pay these people yeah you
can charge 50 to 75 or more an hour as a
handyman in your neighborhood yeah my
handyman said I go to people's
neighborhoods some of these wealthy
neighborhoods I've changed out a light
bulb and they're happy to have me there
yeah and you're you're helping these
people out so get a post in a
neighborhood Facebook group and say hey
I'm willing and able here's my rate and
do it Word of Mouth happens and all of a
sudden you just doubled your income I
just paid the man to come to the house
and hang the TV on the wall I couldn't
believe how much it costs all right
thanks for the call Brett let's take
another one we got Gordon in Des Moines
Iowa what's going on Gordon
Hi how are you guys doing today we're
doing great how are you
I'm doing pretty well I uh I don't know
it's another day with a brand new baby
oh oh you're in the throes okay now I
understand how can we help I mean
there's so much my guy is tired George
he's tired a little bit but it's a happy
tired good good
yeah
um so my question is actually quite
similar to uh to Brett the last caller
he
um I am a welder working full-time 40
hours a week
um
and well at least but I get paid weekly
and I'm trying to figure out how to do a
monthly budget on a weekly paycheck
um and like in in the every dollar app
I've separated
uh separated it out in four paychecks
um
and I don't know it just I I can't quite
figure it out there and it seems like
I'm
losing
losing money somewhere so kind of making
me mad well I got you it can be
frustrating so you're using every dollar
do you have the the premium version
yes okay so on the desktop for sure
um it should be on your mobile device
too but there's something in there
called paycheck planning and I think
that's really going to be helpful for
you because you're going to be able to
space out and actually like plan out
when you're gonna use each piece of
money that you've budgeted for because
each expense you'll Mark the due date
and it will show you in every dollar
when you would run out of money so that
you can adjust move things around change
a due date on a bill and be proactive
about that yeah because when you're
getting paid weekly you've got to be
smart about holding back some money you
know and when it's time to pay otherwise
you're going to come up on moments where
it's like okay like why don't I have
enough to pay my car note what's going
on here so I would suggest using that
paycheck planning feature uh it's only a
part of every dollar premium so if you
don't have premium and you're wondering
you're like Jade what the heck are you
talking about you got to have the
premium version and you can literally
like George said plan out when you're
going to spend each line item in your
budget so that you don't have to worry
about not having enough money when bills
are due not overdraft Ding and having
enough money to do the things that you
need to do and that you'll want to do
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show my
name is Jade warshaw I am joined by my
host George camel and we are taking
calls today about your life and your
money it's a free call that's what Dave
always says although I don't think
people pay for calls these days George
it's Triple Eight they might need to
start charging Jade if they start
getting Snappy with us junk fees triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number if you want to give us a
call we're talking about anything going
on in your life your money you're having
trouble budgeting you don't think you
need to have a zero credit score you're
trying to buy a house I mean you name it
we're gonna talk about it today so let's
go to the phone lines we got Andrew in
San Francisco California what's going on
Andrew
hey Jane hey George I was just laughing
I hope you don't start charging for this
call
you sound like a nice guy yeah you're a
good dude
anyways I'm a big fan I've been
listening for a while so thank you again
for your time absolutely
yeah my question here my wife and I here
um we have no kids we live in the Bay
area and we all know how expensive it is
here and I my the big question that
everyone asks you is like how do we even
begin to say for something like a home
and um and retirement the next few years
should we be thinking about moving
moving down to California ultimately
um yeah nothing even the details as we
go forth but that's that's the big
question sure that's a great question um
can I ask do you guys have any debt
right now
yeah we do uh I can list them all for
you if that's does that work yeah sure
okay yeah so the big one is going to be
our student loans um it's roughly around
90k okay and that's for both of us
um and we're both students right now
we're both working with both students as
well are you currently paying cash for
school or are you going into more
student loan debt
I just got interested in a little bit
for my masters yeah what's the Masters
in
uh semesters in design uh human computer
interaction so it'll be more than 90k
when it's all said and done
no no that's it that's okay okay great
yeah all right keep going down yeah yeah
this is probably yeah it's getting
closer sorry so 90k for student loans
and then uh 6K for a car loan and then
6K for a credit card okay
um what's your income right now I know
you're both in school but
yeah um so I'm working full-time we're
both working full-time and students
full-time so um I I make around 130k uh
a year post bonus and she makes around
36k a year what kind of bonuses do you
make
I think I think around 10 to 12 on that
a year okay
um and she yeah she's a caretaker so I'm
not sure if his bonus is there she just
started again about she's in school to
be an RN she has two years left and I
graduate this September
cool and you'll go straight to the
workforce will you increase your income
once you have that Masters
um so the idea I've been working uh as a
in the industry for about almost four
years now and I I went back to school
last year uh to get on last year's and
so
um I think under 30k so yeah it's a lot
lower than probably Bay Area standards
but um
I'm looking to hopefully open my own
thing because I do make I have some side
hustles as well and your wife's her
income is going to go up obviously when
she becomes a registered nurse
yeah yeah that's that's the plan I think
it's you know anywhere up from I don't
know 80 to 120 whatever it is in the bay
right I mean you've got a lot of options
I think that if I were you I would let
this play out a little bit
um you've got debt to pay off and right
now you've got the income to to make
Headway on that debt and start getting
it paid off and walk through the baby
steps now when the time comes and you
get to baby step 3B and you're saving
for a down payment life is going to look
a lot different than it does now income
wise and just the state of the world we
don't you know in the next two to three
years we don't know exactly what things
are going to look like but the good
thing is this the fields that you guys
are in you can do that anywhere you
don't have to be in the Bay Area if you
don't want to and ultimately you know
you're going to make those decisions
based off of where do we see ourselves
what's important what's a priority to us
and you know I do think it's important
to have home ownership in your future
um if you truly want to build wealth I
think that's a huge part of it
um and who knows with your income the
way it's going it may be possible for
you guys you're gonna have to buckle
down get out of this debt quickly and
really start working this plan so that
when the time comes you can afford these
down payments so that you can buy real
estate in that area and if for some
reason you're not there yet and you're
like looking around the country and
you're like hey you know Iowa's looking
pretty good right now you know that's
it's your prerogative you know I I think
that there's something really freeing
when you kind of allow yourself the
ability to make the the world in the
United States your oyster you know you
don't have to stay in the Bay Area yeah
these ultra high cost of living areas
you also need an ultra high income in
order to survive there there's no rule
that says if you make you know 20 grand
a year or you get to live in Manhattan
and so the key for you guys is to
understand it may feel like a long time
but six years ain't that long and so if
you guys start making 300 Grand a year
which is very possible with where you
guys are headed well we're gonna take a
year and pay off the 100 Grand of debt
we can do that making 300 Grand and now
we freed up all those payments we can
save up over 100 Grand a year and throw
it towards the down payment and so now
within five years we have half a million
dollars to put down on a million dollar
condo who knows what it is in San
Francisco yeah and now we have a 500 000
mortgage we're making 300 Grand and
we're gonna start attacking that house
once we're investing and so it's not
that far it's not a 20-year Journey but
it's also not a two-year Journey that's
right so map it out yeah I'm sorry how
old are you guys
I turned 30 in August and she's um
turning 29 in June all right awesome so
we got some time here we got some time
to work this out and George made a
really good point you know six years it
all depends on how you you know how you
view that it's it's a long time but it's
not a long time you know what I'm saying
well there's a lot of emotion wrapped up
in that I just see Jade I mean six years
from now who knows what inflation will
do in the housing market yeah but guess
what six years is going to be here
regardless and so I'd rather be saving
up a giant pile of money versus just
complaining and not doing anything about
it absolutely the case and you know just
to give people some some good feeling
about this you know I think a lot of
times we think about home ownership
starting a family all of these things
and we feel like for some reason I had
to have done this in my 20s and if I too
late if I didn't get married in my 20s
if I didn't have kids in my 20s if I
didn't buy a house in my 20s if I didn't
start investing in my 20s then it's too
late for you and I'm like George if it
was too late in the 20s then I may as
well give up on life because I didn't
get started can I just tell you guys
Sam and I were married we were married
for 10 years and then we decided to
start a family
so number one that's different because
most people are popping out these babies
early on oh yeah then we decided to uh
wait to buy a home because we needed to
do things the right way and then we had
to wait to invest we did not purchase
our first home until age 35. we did not
start investing until age 36 and your
life isn't over my life is not over I'm
just getting started I was looking at
the the portfolio the other day and I
said this is not bad Life's a lot better
now than it was 10 years ago yes 15
years ago yes so the key is make
progress make progress not excuses and
don't let whatever somebody else is
doing make you feel like you're behind
because your life is your life you run
your race don't look to the right don't
look to the left you look straight ahead
and run your race are your friends who
are broke and they just look good and on
the other side are your in-laws who are
questioning why you don't give them
grandkids yet and how you don't have a
house because they paid 11.99 on a
bushel of raspberries for their house
back in 1985 and it should be easy for
you too because they pulled them so
elves up by their bootstraps Jade and
you need to do this listen you've got to
shut down all of that noise and put up
the boundaries and you need to get laser
focused on what your life is going to
look like what your race is going to
look like because if we start chasing
after other people's marathons there is
no Finish Line at the end there's no
frustrated there's no Finish Line at the
end and so you guys can do this you can
have the life that you want you've just
got to walk through the steps and do it
the right way I know he's excited to get
a house there's a lot of other folks
that are excited to get a house too but
you want to do it the right way okay and
and it matters so uh let me see if I can
get through this real quick uh the truth
is if you're living a debt-free
lifestyle eventually you're not going to
have a credit score and we know that and
you're going to want to buy a house and
you're going to want to find a good
lender like Churchill Mortgage who can
help you do manual underwriting that's
where they personally review your
financial history to approve you for a
mortgage so you don't need a credit
score so if you're interested in that
you can go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and that's what we're talking
about George having the life we want
doing it the right way that's the theme
this hour is rising above this broken
system and realizing that not only is it
better but there's so much more joy and
freedom and options on the other side
and you realize oh I don't miss my
credit score I don't miss my credit card
rewards I don't miss having to play this
stupid game that has caused me to be
broke
that's all it takes is you deciding and
then being about the business of doing
it I'm not trying to play these games
anymore George I don't want to do some
rap Maze and you feel like you won
because you get the cheese but you're
stuck in a maze it wasn't that good to
begin with get out of the maze all right
that does it for today's show be sure to
join us next time and remember when it
comes to changing your life and your
money yeah you can tell me that you
won't do it but you better not tell me
that you can't do it because I know for
a fact all things are possible with God
on your side
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help Hope people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm your
host today Jade warshaw I'm joined by my
favorite guy right here next to you on
this show George Campbell I can't wait
to tell Ken and John about that it's
shots fired I'm gonna have four feelings
they're so sensitive you know George I
say the same thing about them too so
there you go I think the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a call we'll chop it up
with you we got Brett on the line from
Washington DC what's going on Brett
hi there thanks for taking my call I'm
my question today is how do I draw
boundaries when supporting a family
member who's been charged with a crime
and likely facing
um incarceration
sorry to hear that Brett how close is
the family member
uh immediate family member wow
um who has a family and kids how many
kids
uh two
are they pretty young
and How likely is the incarceration
um it's I I think it's going to be
likely okay and do you know the length
of time that it would be
um just six months or 20 years uh it's
in between there it's in the Years okay
I think probably five or longer okay so
we're talking about helping this family
out for five to ten years potentially
I I think so
it's a little daunting
um at this point right thinking about
that yeah
how are you doing financially
um I I'm lucky or or we're doing well
and and even in immediate terms right
like the most immediate things like
retaining
um counsel and
um any bail situations like those things
I've been able to cover and cash flow
okay
have you talked to this family yet about
what their needs are
we've been
um actively supporting them
um both kind of emotionally as well as
even you know having them over and and
staying with us right
um but we haven't gone too far I think
we're taking things one day at a time
are they living with you right now
they will be they will be is that long
term or is that a temporary fix have you
guys talked about that temporary fix
there there have been some discussions
um where I think good thing is there is
there's family on both sides who can be
supportive
um I I think the details are not quite
there right in terms of
um who all is going to chip in how much
things like that it's just I just
imagine there's going to be a component
that of support it's going to be a
village yeah here's the two things that
come to my mind if I'm being honest
um I'm trying to put myself in your
shoes as best as possible and the two
things that are coming to mind are
how you're feeling or how I might feel
when something kind of gets dropped in
in your lap and it's not because of
anything you did it's not anything that
you know it just is set in your lap and
it's like all right I gotta react to
this and you've done a great job
handling bails stepping in and and cash
flowing this and my first thought is
make sure you take care of yourself
mentally because you don't want to start
feeling
um any bitterness or spite or like oh
like I can't believe I have to do this
this guy you know I don't know the
nature of what took place it doesn't
matter but all I know is you're on the
hook for it and you feel on the hook for
it
um so there's a piece there's a
component there that I'm thinking about
um and then on the financial side you
know you said you guys are doing well
financially you don't have any debt
correct
um that's right just a mortgage just a
mortgage
um and it sounds like you know within
your day-to-day cash flow within your
budget you've got money that you can put
to put towards this but it doesn't mean
that you have to
um and so I kind of want to give you
permission to say no sometimes now if
you want to be generous and you want to
participate
um I think that's great but I also want
to say very loud and clear you're not
required
um to do anything here except you know
you can provide counsel but you're not
required to do anything monetarily
um and I think starting there is a great
way to start and then you can decide
what you would like to do does that make
sense
it does
it does so how much are you thinking
about let's say if there was a monthly
contribution limit I almost look at this
like a mission organization that I want
to support and me and my wife have a
conversation about what we're both okay
with contributing uh maybe and we do it
in your chunks and say we're going to
commit to one year we're going to give
you 200 a month every month for this
year
have you had that kind of conversation
with your spouse
not yet
um not yet I think having all of that
real clear up front helps because a lot
of people what creates the the toxicity
in these relationships and the
resentment is when the expectations
weren't set they weren't communicated
and now we're going well no I thought
this money was forever and I thought it
was just however much we need whenever
we want right versus saying hey we're
happy to give here's how much we're able
to give right now uh that could change
in the future it could go up it could go
down based on where we're at financially
and what we can do and I think if
everyone in the conversation in this
Village has that conversation with each
other and as a group you're going to
have a lot clearer boundaries as to what
this looks like going forward absolutely
and there's another component about that
too uh George that you made me think
about
um I know a lot of times with churches
when they do benevolence or do do things
to help out in the community they don't
just give monetary amounts to folks you
know folks come to the doors and it's
like hey you know single mom I'm
suffering with this or I'm having a hard
time paying the more gauge they don't
just give them you know seven eight
hundred dollars they go and pay the
mortgage they go right in and pay the
light bill so I kind of want to advise
you in that way not to just hand out
money and not to hand out cash but
actually go in and do those items like
if it's if it's for rent you pay the
rent if it's for lights you pay the
actual light bill that way it's just
another way to make sure that you're
feeling good and that you have some bit
of control over how this money that
you're generously giving it's okay for
you to have control over how it's spent
and sometimes the best thing we can do
is not just to give a pile of money
every month but to actually empower the
person to change their life and take
control of it and so the spouse that's
the now taking care of these kids on
their own are they able to work and are
you able to support them in that way to
get them on their feet to where they can
provide for themselves yeah
um I think I can provide some coaching
it is a tough situation
um the spouse
um it has been a stay-at-home mom
um and it's been a long time since she's
been in Workforce well here's what I
want to do I want to gift you with
Financial Peace University and I want
you to gift that to the the wife so that
she can figure out you know what her
footing is moving forward she's going to
learn all the principles of money she's
going to learn how to pay off debt she's
going to learn how to save she's going
to learn how to do all of those
necessary things that are going to be
really important for her uh going
forward so hang on the line and Austin
will get that for you guys I'm gonna add
in one more thing Dr John deloney's book
own your past change your future because
there's a lot of trauma in the situation
on a lot of things we got to learn how
to move forward with that's right great
great call thank you so much for that
call hopefully we were able to help you
out this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsey show my
name is Jay this is George sitting next
to me and we're taking calls about your
life your money your financial situation
what's bothering you in the world as it
relates to finance what is a problem for
you in the world as it relates to
finance your life your money give us a
call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five now here you go for those
of you out here listening that don't
know my personal story let me tell you a
little something my husband and I paid
off 460
000 of debt I don't know where y'all
come from but where I come from that's
suspiciously close to half a million
dollars George all right when we did
this we paid it off guys working the
baby steps we talk about this every day
on the show uh the same baby steps that
we teach in Financial Peace University
now Financial Peace University it's a
nine week class that shows you how to
beat debt and here's the thing
and build wealth what we're talking
about on this show the baby steps it's
not just about debt-free debt-free debt
free debt free we're trying to build
wealth up in here George we've got to
remember that so that you live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else and let me tell you
guys
I believe in this class Financial Peace
University so much uh that I help lead
classes I'm leading an FPU class right
now as a matter of fact we started last
night it's going amazing and I'm leading
classes because this changes lives it
changes lives it's doing it all over the
world and um I'm telling you there's
nothing special about me though all
right I'm just like you just like all
y'all listening out here so leading an
FPU class isn't just for those people
it's not just for Jade or or George or
Dave it's for you too you can actually
start helping folks now it might seem
scary to lead a class but you need to do
it anyway and I'm telling you right now
it's not scary they tell you exactly
what to do exactly what to say because
there are people out there now you feel
scared they they feel scared and they
need you they're scared to open their
bills every month they're scared to
check their bank account and they need
you because you guys know how to do this
and you can I'm telling you to be a
coordinator it's so easy you just follow
the plan they tell you exactly what to
say so you guys can do this you don't
have to be debt freedom a millionaire to
lead a class you just have to be
passionate and believe in what we teach
and that's most of you listening out
there that is such a good point George I
think a lot of people think well if I'm
in baby step two who am I to teach this
stuff you're even even better even
better because that means you're right
there with them you're walking along
with them and not only is it going to be
encouraging to them it's also going to
be encouraging to you as well on your
journey so right now I want you to go
online I want you to type in
ramsesolutions.com
lead to learn more about becoming an FPU
that's Financial Peace University
coordinator go to ramseysolutions.com
lead super important stuff George love
it all right let's take a call we got
Nathan in Sarasota Florida what's going
on Nate Dogg
hey how are you guys today I'm doing
good sorry about the Nate Dog are you
okay with Nate Dogg
I guess he is now sometimes I I can't
resist sorry about that Nathan what you
got going on
so I'm 20 and I've been living on my own
since I was 18 and I'm things are
getting pretty serious me and my
girlfriend
and I'm just curious on
potentially we want to get married in
the next three years and I'm
just wondering if it's a bad idea to
rent
if we're not ready to buy a house or
should we wait where'd you get the idea
that it was a bad idea to rent
um I'm
ah there it is I figured that much and
they're saying hey what Nathan why would
you throw money away on rent when you
can get into a house and start building
Equity is that the basically what
they're saying
pretty pretty on there okay well I'll
tell you this much we never recommend
someone buy a house before they're ready
and we also recommend that newlyweds
rent for a while before they buy a house
because you got enough going on with the
stress of a wedding I mean it is like a
it's like being in a car crash it can be
traumatic just so much stress compacted
for this one big party we're throwing
everyone and then you're also going oh
that's your side of the that's my side
no we got we got issues here and so
you're already trying to navigate
newlywed life on top of home ownership
that's just a lot at once emotionally
mentally financially and so there is
nothing wrong with renting and I want to
be here to dispel the myth that renting
is a sin and tell you that renting is a
great thing to do and it gives you such
flexibility and when something goes
wrong you call someone to come fix it
while you guys sit there and eat ice
cream and be cute I know that's right I
like that George so that's the plan are
you guys having any debt currently
um she doesn't she actually um got
scholarships all through she um just
about to graduate um State College here
in the next two months this is a green
flag for this relationship Nathan I'm
liking this already you don't have any
debt right
no ma'am I don't I didn't go to school
and um sweet I've just kind of
it's kind of been I never really like I
don't like owing people money I hate it
as it is that's always how I've been
myself
so I never told my mom I never want to
go to college so I got into a trade and
I've been Plumbing for two years now
it's great so so let's just walk this
through let's say you guys you get
married we're gonna cash flow the
wedding we're gonna save up for the
engagement ring so you already have some
financial goals ahead of you
yes sir and so if we can start our
marriage off completely debt free with a
cash flow wedding and have a fully
funded emergency fund that is a win in
my book as far as starting a marriage
off on the right foot and just to be
clear you're doing these things separate
of one another on your own so you're
saving up your nest egg for the wedding
she's saving up her nest egg for the
wedding and you're saving up money your
nest egg for you know three to six
months of savings she's saving up her
nest egg and then when you get together
uh you can go ahead and combine those
finances does that sound good to you
Nathan
yes awesome awesome you know it's really
funny George uh I read a stat that said
only 43 percent of couples combine their
finances yikes married couples so we're
talking about 57 percent of people go
uh-uh that's my money well it's crazy
yeah it's such a crazy thought to me
it's nuts that you'll you'll share a
spit in a bed and DNA but you can't
share a bank account it's different what
is wrong with you people well it's even
crazier because here's the thing these
are real studies that show uh married
couples that combine their money they
build wealth four times faster uh
because they're more likely to purchase
a home together
they're more likely to stay together
over the Long Haul of their marriage and
it literally said this they are happier
I believe that they're happier think
about it you got a closed fist you're
living your life with where you're going
this is my money and that's your money
and you spend what you want to spend
I'll spend what I want to spend you
don't get to tell me how I spend my
money and you have those kind of control
issues you're not you're not going to
get very far but when you live life with
an open hand going this is our money and
our life what could we do together you
will go so much further together so much
further it's it's just unbelievable to
me I I don't get it maybe we have time
to take a quick call let's make this one
fast we got Daniel get to it fast we're
up against the clock
hello
um I was calling in because I'm curious
if I should invest in a Roth IRA because
I'm I'm 16 and I just started a job at
uh Subway working on the weekends I was
wondering if it's too early to invest in
a Roth or if I should start like doing
like The Nest Egg Baby Steps because
like my parents are really good I have a
place to live they they like help me
with like food and like go they only
look like food and uh so you have no
debt nothing like that
I don't have any debt I don't have any
like need to spend money really it's
only like stuff that I want that I'm
sure you have a car yes
uh no I actually live close enough to my
work to bike there cool I haven't gotten
the car yet okay well I love the idea of
investing I just want to make sure that
our upcoming financial goals for example
you know higher education do you plan on
going to school
to college I'm planning on doing I'm
actually planning on doing
certifications for it because I want to
work in it and from what I've read
college isn't really the best way to get
into IKEA service stations way to go man
go to CNA well I'd make sure we can cash
flow a car purchase because you're gonna
need that sooner rather than later make
sure we can cash flow the certification
so I might just be saving all this money
in a high yield savings account right
now because we the next few years
there's a lot of financial goals that we
might have to hit but if you can do that
and have an emergency fund and you get
out on your own you're going to be
investing in no time I mean the fact
you're even talking about this you're
going to be a multi-millionaire probably
in your 40s at this point and so I love
the idea of investing but I might pause
until I have a full-time job I love that
there's a right way and there's a best
way to do this I like to say it like
that there's a best way to do this and
make sure your education is there and
make sure your your Investments are
there we want to do it in the right
order so I just like that he's thinking
about it I was a knucklehead at 16. I
still am this kid's Sharp I love it we
love to see it we love when the young
folks call in the show uh this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey show my
name is Jade warshaw this is George
Campbell and uh George you showed me
something really crazy I found a break
now there's a lot of tweets that make me
angry and there's a lot of tweets that
make me laugh this one somehow did both
and so I wanted to share it with you
Jade and all of our listeners out there
and get your take on it so uh boys throw
up that tweet
so this is a tweet from someone that
says
finally paid off my vodka crayon from
last month God is good with a little
praise emoji and it's a receipt from
afterpay they put a 12 cocktail on
payments
for easy payments on a 12 cocktail no no
no and not God is good no don't throw
God he had nothing to do with it this is
your stupidity oh Lord don't blame him
don't thank him
this is crazy and and it's after pay I I
could tell it's after pay based on the
logo I know these scumbers I I'm sure so
this is if you all don't know the this
is the new thing that gen Z's into which
is buy now pay later so they're
anti-credit cards but they're Pro
payments because they're going well
there's no interest so how bad can it be
it's bad payments on a drink because
think about it that's one interaction
that's one time going out you keep
adding that to your tab with your
payments and all of a sudden you go okay
well I only spent 25 of what I would
have spent which leaves room in my
budget so that I can pay after pay the
next month and the next month and the
next month let me that's insane if you
I'm just gonna say if you have to put a
12 drink on payments you are a hot flame
of a flame of a mess
you're just a Hot Flaming funky mess
it's it's gotten real bad out there Jade
and these companies you've heard of them
after Pay Here's their tagline get what
you want we've got your back okay that's
that's a great way to create an entire
generation that's broke wow here's the
firms pay at your own pace that's what
hey hey pay at your own pace no rush
we're happy to wait we'll take another
payment next month and then Clarin is my
favorite
get financial breathing room because
nothing says breathing room like being
chained
what oh my goodness and here's what gets
me Clara also brags to the retailers
that use this program
that the consumer will spend up to 45
percent more if you have klarna as an
option
they know what they're doing well duh
that's why they make billions of dollars
and you remain broke but instead you go
no Jade it's smart I'm I'm leaving room
in my budget Jade what do you mean I I
can't even breathe right now George I
can't even breathe you need to use
klarna because they'll give you some
Breathing Room apparently oh okay and
don't get a drink while I'm at it vodka
cran look I read a stat that said 57 of
people who use buy now pay later
regretted
their purchase buy now regret later
that's the new name how about just buy
now pay now that feels like the way God
and grandma would do it hot diggity
we're gonna bring God into this yeah
it's insane to me what if you just
popped out a ten dollar bill in a single
two singles and just pay for that 12
drink
I mean blowing my mind oh God just make
your drinks at home people you know do
it like we do in smart money happy hour
okay we're on a budget out here we're
not going to these crazy cocktail bars
and by the way it's just it's all
watered down it tastes gross yeah it's
just done going out I'm too I'm like an
old curmudgeon of a man jade look you're
telling me Nashville cocktails are now
20 bucks and they have a liquor tax of
an extra 15 on top of the 10 in
Nashville and I'm like I'm just done you
know I'm going to the crib I'm going to
the crib I'ma pour my Eagle Rare in my
in my in my glass with my Square Cube
because I'm not going to one of these
restaurants trust and believe I'm not
going to Applebee's getting an old
fashioned where there's like 0.00
of drink in the drink you know what I'm
saying I'll stick to my water that's
what I eat when I when I go out I get
water because I'm too cheap and I have
money I just I'm like this ain't worth
it it's not worth not paying the
premiums it never well I'm not paying in
four payments exactly goodness George I
okay all right now that we're piled up
I'm glad we got this out of our system
so we have to talk about something Jade
we get calls on occasion on the show
from folks that have disabilities yes
they're they're blind they're deaf um a
lot of these people you know have had
these a long time since they were young
and because of that they're on
disability income yes SSDI and the
problem with that is that the government
limits you to how much money you have to
your name and the limit is very very low
two thousand dollars total at any given
moment is the limit you that's just to
remain eligible for your benefits that's
poverty I mean that's
unbelievable George yeah it's really sad
all right so what are the options here
because we get people calling in and
it's like hey I want to I want to work
the baby steps I want to do things to
get my income up but if I get my income
up too high then I don't get this
benefit but they're also afraid to lose
the benefit because then they've they're
responsible for their life their
insurance all of those things so it is
it is a very precarious situation yeah
so here's here's one option either
you've got to learn how to on how to
live your life with that low disability
income due to how extreme the disability
is or a better option if you're able to
based on the nature of your disability
if you can do some type of work yes you
will be way better off financially
because you're not stuck under these
insanely rigid rules for your your
income and your assets absolutely I mean
I want to make it very clear if you are
on this disability we're not mad at you
like we we're not saying hey if you're
taking this money you know you're wrong
or there's something wrong with you no
not at all we're just letting you see
that this is the choice that you have to
make and I'll be honest when I look at
two thousand dollars it's very I'm like
how and within with everything going on
that is that's more scary to me than
going out because I feel like with the
internet there's a lot of ways that some
some of these folks might be able to get
get above that and they'd be surprised
what they can do because you've got
something to offer absolutely you've got
there's something that you're good at
there's some service that you have to
offer
um and you can make there's so many ways
you can make money today George yes and
so there is an option for those with
disabilities to where they can have more
than two thousand dollars and it's it's
not illegal it's called an able account
and it's basically a savings account
where you can have up to one hundred
thousand dollars without affecting your
disability income and what's cool is
that family members can gift money into
this love this so it is a good option
for those and some people don't know
about it and we've got some emails
coming in from people that go hey I just
heard this call from this person with
disability you got to let them know
about the able account so this is a tax
advantage savings account for those with
disabilities and their families there
are some restrictions as to who's
eligible for this yeah so you have to
have been diagnosed with your disability
before the age age of 26. yep so if
that's you uh you most likely are
eligible for this and what makes me sad
this is straight from from one of the
able sites it says to remain eligible
for these public benefits an individual
must remain poor that is the most
frustrating sentence I've heard in a
long long time well I I think it's
it's just frustrating it's like you're
helping but you're also hurting because
the real help would be like Can it can
it be enough to live on
because that's barely enough now I think
I'm thankful for this able deal because
you can add money to that but you know
again the choice is all about helping
you build wealth and be generous and
have control over your finances and it's
really hard to prosper when you have a
limited income and limited ability to
save and the government is ensuring that
you are their slave at this point with
this program I kind of feel like they're
selling these folks short because
they're scared to let go of it Jade and
while they're getting into these they're
getting into some of these folks head in
making them think I need this and I I
can't go beyond this and now for some
people listening that may be the best
choice for you you know sticking on the
2000 getting connected with able but for
some of these people listening I think
that we just need to infuse hope and and
let you know hey you've got something to
offer there are opportunities out there
for you and I think that you can make
more than two thousand absolutely I I
wouldn't take much to hit that threshold
and here's the thing with the able
accounts I want you all to know about
people with disabilities and family
members can deposit up to seventeen
thousand dollars in an able account for
twenty twenty three so that is the limit
for this year you might be able to
contribute more money if you have a job
and you're able to work you can do an
additional thirteen thousand five
hundred ninety dollars if you're in the
US continentally so very there are
options out there I want to make sure
those that are out there with
disabilities and if you've got a loved
one in your life please send them this
information we want to help everyone
this is a show and the content is for
everyone in all walks of life and yes
it's harder if you've got a disability I
don't want to minimize that but I also
want to encourage you guys that you have
so much to offer and that this doesn't
have to hold you back this could be a
part of your story that inspires others
along the journey and you can still
build wealth but you've got to make this
happen on your terms and not the
government if you're doing that call in
and tell us about it we'd love to hear I
want you to call in and I want you to
tell us what you're doing it's going to
encourage somebody else to do the same
thing this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show my
name is Jade warshaw next to me to my
right my right hand man George camel and
we've got a scripture and quote of the
day for you it's this it says be kind to
one another be compassionate forgiving
each other just as God and Christ has
also forgiven you that's Ephesians 4 32
and Kenny Loggins said this the more we
stretch the muscle called compassion and
generosity the stronger we get the
better we feel about ourselves the more
loving we become to the world around us
oh beautiful words from one of my
favorite artists Kenny Loggins I mean
the hits go on Jade Footloose danger
zone this is it can't wait for his
upcoming concert but which of us is
going to that concert George that's
right that's right I'm coming to that
concert yeah 75 years old the man's
still out there doing the thing he can
sing higher and better than ever I'm
just letting you know that means Dave's
got no excuse he better be behind this
chair at 75. still crushing the game he
will be don't you worry about that give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
take your call we got Harry in Salt Lake
City what's going on Harry
not a whole lot Jay and George thanks
for taking my call of course
so my question today my wife and I were
uh we've paid off about 15 000 in debt
and uh we just have two debts left we
have a personal loan and student loans
uh the personal loan is about seven
thousand left and student loans is 29
000.
um with the pause on the student loan
payments should we make any payments to
that at all or should we just continue
to stay focused on that person alone
yeah I think that's a Temptation that a
lot of people are feeling right now to
kind of you know Loop it out of order
now I do have one question the student
loan is it just one student loan for 29
000 or is it broken up into pieces
it's all Consolidated in 29 000. yeah
well you know what I'm going to tell you
to go ahead and just work the debt
snowball in order I think that's the
best way to do it because you're gonna
you're gonna feel those wins and that
you need that to keep going You're Gonna
uh how fast can you knock out this next
seven thousand
uh my wife and I have panned it out
um we make about a hundred thousand uh
as a household and within the next four
months we'll have it paid off awesome
but you're saying hey the student loans
are paused completely should I even make
minimum payments on those because we say
debt snowball making minimum payments on
all your debts except the first one
you're saying should I pay a dime
towards these well I'll Attack it that's
a good call out George yeah make minimum
payments
make minimum payments that's the way the
snowball works the snowball works is you
make minimum payments on all the debt
and put any extra money on the smallest
debt and that way when it's unpaused
you've already been flexing that muscle
making that payment plus the extras
going towards the debt and so when that
gets unpaused and it eventually will as
much as they keep kicking it down the
road man you're going to be in control
and so I'm pumped for you that you're
like I want to attack all of this debt I
just want to know the best way to do it
instead of waiting on someone else to
fix it all heck yeah that's exciting I
can't wait for you guys when's the
when's the debt free when's debt free
day
that free day we're still trying to
figure that out we're we're hoping maybe
in the next uh 12 to 18 months well that
is super I'm making 100 Grand paying off
what 36. heck it's feasible that is
exciting exciting stuff thanks for the
call Harry let's see what Jay's talking
about in New York City what's going on
Jay
hey thanks for taking my call no problem
I'm actually I'm actually a police
officer in New York I have four years on
the job and I have 16 years less until I
am eligible to retire and I'm 35 years
old
um currently I have about 40K in
deferred I mean traditional retirement
um offered through my employer and they
just now gave us the opportunity to
switch over to a different uh a Ross
option okay and I was wondering if I
should make that move or not
great question so you're 35 you said
you've got 15 years until you can retire
16. uh one six six 16 years until I'm
eligible to retire and at that point
I'll be able to leave making 50 of my
salary which should keep me at around a
hundred thousand dollars a year okay
that's awesome yeah I wouldn't touch the
current Investments but if you want to
start contributing to the Roth side for
future investing I think that's a great
move at your age
okay so yeah because currently I'm
already contributing 20 to the
traditional you think I should just go
all in and stop doing it and go straight
to 20 to the raw I would go 15 until you
have a paid for house do you have a paid
for house
nope I am completely debt free
um I moved back at home with my parents
because I'm single and I figured you
know what they're going to be moving to
Florida in a few years so I'm going to
hang out until until they move along and
uh maybe purchase their house that's a
cool goal so if you go down to 15 I
would use that five percent you now have
back in your life to begin saving
towards that future house purchase
whether it's in the next five years the
next 15 years and the the idea here with
the Roth is that you're using your
after-tax dollars but then the money's
gonna grow tax-free and so either way if
you crunch the numbers it would be the
same so what we're actually talking
about here is what your tax bracket will
be when you're older and we're basically
saying we think taxes will go up over
the course of history and so therefore
having tax-free money is going to be
better and so there's a it's a hot
debate in the among the finance nerds
out there but I personally would rather
have that tax-free money uh with no
required minimum distributions because
Uncle Sam's already got his cut and so I
like that plan and if I have two million
dollars in a Roth 401k I have two
million dollars to my name that I can do
what I want with without paying taxes
and that's just a good feeling I like
that does that answer your question Jay
absolutely that's huge yeah way to go
and thank you for your service I mean
being a police officer in New York
that's serious business oh yeah I know
that's right I'm thinking about the fact
that he's moving into his parents house
and thinking about buying his parents
house I was like that's that's that's a
different move you got to have some type
of great relationship with your family
to do that yeah I don't know if I could
do that I love my parents
I love my parents but oh it can't happen
let me just put it like that it cannot
happen oh my goodness gracious so we've
got every once in a while we get
questions on social media and I've got
here one I've got one here from a a dude
in Georgia his name is Evan and he says
my wife and I have twenty three thousand
two hundred fifty dollars in debt and
two credit cards in a vehicle I work two
jobs and she works one we have a newborn
and are currently renting we have 12K in
savings and I have paused my retirement
of 10 the question is should we use any
of our savings toward the debt oh this
feels like one of those riddles that you
you know in math class
Georgia at 48 miles an hour okay so the
Crux of the question is I've got 12 000
in debt I'm trying to work the Ramsay
plan yeah he's paused retirement which
is an awesome step yeah
and you're going do I let go of the
savings which is such an emotional
decision for most people they cannot
fathom the idea of going down to a
thousand dollars which is what we
recommend I mean yeah I get it it's like
a a safety net it's a it's a a blankie
if you will you know myself I like that
it's a blankie my son has this blanket
it's old and torn up and he's had it
since the day he's born and he I mean if
I went up to him and I took that blank
oh oh you're gonna catch a eye Jammy oh
yeah here's some hands yeah he's got
you're gonna catch some hands oh my
goodness so yes I would use eleven
thousand of your 12 000 in savings to go
towards your 23 000 in debt and maybe
that vehicle gets sold if you want to
speed up this process and get that
savings account back up faster and so
depending on what the car is worth you
know if you if you owe 10 on the car and
you can sell it for 12 or 15 or whatever
it is and you get yourself a beater car
for a little while until you get back up
to baby step three then I think that
could be a good move for you I like it
you know the the theme that we keep
coming across as we take these calls
especially the calls that are kind of
related to the baby steps and doing the
baby steps in order
discomfort is required
um it's required you can't get around it
and I think what gets people kind of
going off track and it's like oh I don't
know if I want to touch the savings to
pay off the debt I don't know if I want
to stop my retirement contribution to
pay off the debt it's that Comfort valve
people think oh I don't want to get
discomfort I don't want to get out you
know and you have to you have to embrace
discomfort to do this process and we're
just we're humans and so we're creatures
of habit and so anything that's changed
is difficult so the day you go all right
am I going to submit myself to someone
else's plan or am I going to be a
financial genius who's broke those are
your options and it's hard to go like I
don't know if that oh that plan my
situation is different I'm unique the
day you realize you're not that special
okay the day you can start winning with
money okay every
evidence through the exception to the
plan oh but
oh but we have six kids and in a van get
that butt out of here no butts around
here okay okay you ain't special you
ain't that's a good thing that means you
can change your life just like everyone
else that's right and that does it for
this hour be sure to join us next time
and remember this when it comes to
changing your life and money you can
tell me you won't do it but please don't
tell me you can't With God all things
are possible
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]